[Music]
for years he was the chief of staff of
the Algerian national army but Ahmed
GERD Salah will mostly be remembered for
being behind the resignation of
president Abdul Aziz put Africa after
two decades in office on March 26 this
year not long after hundreds of
thousands of Algerians marched in the
streets demanding the president stepped
down
it was Garrett's Ellis speech urging
bootiful eager to quit that made that a
reality the army backed the arrests of
many of beautifully cos allies a month
later seller supported the newly
appointed interim leader Abdul Kadir Ben
Saleh I would like to confirm in truth
that the transitional period to prepare
for the presidential elections will take
place with the oversight of the National
People's Army which will keep watch over
the course of this transition in light
of the mutual trust between the people
and their army just last week get Sela
attended the inauguration of the new
president Abdul Majid have one but many
protesters that boycotted the election
that brought into power saying those
little choice of candidates beyond the
established elite get sella spent his
entire adult life in the Armed Forces a
former officer in the National
Liberation Army he spent years working
his way to the top of the army he fought
in Algeria's war of independence against
the French and was considered a hero in
his country as a close ally to then
president Bouteflika in 2004 he became
chief of staff of the army and 2013 vice
minister of defence in February this
year in a sudden wave of protests
Algerians demanded the entire government
step down
his loyalty to bouteflika had come to an
end
and he joined the calls from protesters
for the president to resign but many
Algerians turn their anger on to get
Salah obviously he is part of the order
the establishment because of different
positions he held in the Algerian
military it's only recently that some of
the protesters were calling for him to
go because as far as they were concerned
he didn't all the helot or the Alec did
not live up to expectations they
expected all they wanted a more open
democratic regime
some protesters are rejecting a
three-day morning and a calling for real
democracy and an end to the military
state
[Music]